cependant une grande guerre se prépare
la serbie et la bulgarie se disputent la
macédoine par les armes se forme alors
deux grandes coalitions
la serbie a lié à la russie à la
roumanie à la grèce au portugal au
royaume uni à la france et à l'italie
contre la bulgarie allié à l'autriche à
l'allemagne et à l' empire ottoman
dans l'héritier du trône austro hongrois
est d'assassiner par des serbes
c'est l'étincelle qui provoque la
première guerre mondiale l'allemagne
envahit la belgique et le luxembourg
arrivant près de paris mais soudain tout
change
l'autriche sort de la guerre une défaite
militaire et une révolution ayant aboli
la monarchie
la première république autrichienne et
proclamé une révolution éclate aussi en
allemagne
l'empereur est obligé d'abdiquer et la
première république allemande coupé en
deux entités territoriales est proclamé
c'est la fin d'année la turquie qui
saoule empire ottoman et passe au statut
de république démocratique
l'ukraine et la biélorussie prennent
leur indépendance vis-à-vis de la russie
la serbie annexe la slovénie la croatie
la macédoine la bosnie herzégovine et le
monténégro formant le royaume de
yougoslavie en russie aussi une
révolution éclate le tsar est éliminé et
l'union des républiques socialistes
soviétiques est proclamé
cela permet à la pologne de renaître
tout comme la finlande l'estonie la
lettonie et la lituanie
la hongrie se détache de l'autriche et
prend son indépendance
les slovaques et les tchèques s'unissent
pour constituer la république de
tchécoslovaquie la roumanie reprend la
moldavie et l'union soviétique reprend
l'ukraine et la biélorussie
l'irlande prend son indépendance et se
renomme et y
mais elle est privée des comtés du nord
qui choisissent de rester dans le
royaume uni
en europe cependant les dangers ne sont
pas tous écartés des dictateurs prennent
le pouvoir
au portugal les militaires suspens des
libertés en italie le roi confie le
gouvernement à mussolini qui établit la
dictature fasciste toutefois mussolini
permet la création de l'état de la cité
du vatican
enclavée dans la ville de rome comme
siège des institutions de l'église
catholique romaine en estonie en
lituanie et en lettonie les militaires
instaure la dictature
en espagne c'est le général franco qui
prend le pouvoir en allemagne
hitler est nommé chancelier et se
proclame fureur
adolf hitler chef d'un parti politique à
l'idéologie nationaliste et raciste
prônant le nazisme ambitionne la
reconstitution de l' empire allemand
d'avant guerre il rattache alors
l'autriche à l'allemagne
reprend les anciens territoires
allemands en tchécoslovaquie et attaque
la pologne la partageant avec l'union
soviétique cela provoque la réaction de
la france et du royaume uni
allié à la pologne la seconde guerre
mondiale éclate le royaume uni attaque
l'allemagne mais hitler contre attaque
il envahit le danemark la norvège les
pays bas la belgique le luxembourg et la
france parvenant même à bombarder le
royaume uni par avion enfin concluant
avec le japon et l'italie
le pacte de lax hitler occupe la
slovaquie et le royaume de hongrie
tandis que l'italie occupe l'albanie et
le royaume de graisse fortement
préoccupé le premier ministre du royaume
uni
winston churchill et le général français
charles de gaulle en exil à londres font
alors appel aux nations du monde pour
former une coalition anti nazi ap les
armées alliées
pour sa part l'union soviétique de
joseph staline ambitionne la domination
de l'europe orientale devenu un état de
régime communiste elle attaque la
finlande l'estonie la lettonie la
lituanie et la roumanie
mais la finlande et la roumanie se
rebelle suivi par la bulgarie et s'allie
à hitler envahit alors le royaume de
yougoslavie et se dirige vers moscou
l'union soviétique à l'armée rejoint le
camp des armées alliées
tout comme les etats-unis et la chine en
guerre contre un membre de l' axe le
japon
le conflit devient mondiale
d'hitler attaque l'immense union
soviétique mais les dures conditions
climatiques de ce pays et qui craint un
quart de cette route des causes non sa
défaite
il est en effet battu par les armes et
communistes qui avance jusqu'à la mer
adriatique établissant leur régime sur
les pays assujettis pour les nazis c'est
la déroute les armées alliées des
etats-unis du canada du royaume uni
attac l'italie et renversent les
fascistes puis elle débarque en france
et n le général de gaulle à chasser et
totalement hitler se suicident
l'allemagne capitule
les pays occupés par les nazis sont
libérés c'est la paix étant les états
unis lancent la bombe atomique sur le
japon
les conflits cesse définitive pour
assurer le maintien de la paix
l'organisation des nations unies est
alors créée sa finalité est le
remplacement des conflits par le
dialogue
mais le cas échéant l'onu peut employer
des casques bleus
sa force armée pour rétablir la paix 51
pays signent la charte des nations unies
dont les membres permanents sont les
états-unis l'union soviétique la chine
la france et le royaume uni
bien qu ayant consenti à rendre son
indépendance à la finlande
l'union soviétique absorbe la tchéquie
et reconstitue la tchécoslovaquie dans
les balkans le maréchal tito fondent la
république fédérale socialiste de
yougoslavie de régime communiste mais
détaché de la tutelle de moscou tout
comme l'albanie qui embrasse le
communisme mais conserve son
indépendance
en allemagne le nazisme est déclaré
illégal et le pays est à nouveau divisé
en deux d'un côté la république fédérale
d'allemagne contrôlé par les armées
alliées et de l'autre la république
démocratique d'allemagne contrôlé par
les soviets
l'europe aussi est divisée
la conférence de yalta entre les deux
puissances victorieuses des états unis
et l'union soviétique partage l'europe
en deux blocs
dans le bloc occidental sous influence
américaine certains pays si l'accord de
l'otan pour se protéger contre
d'éventuelles agressions soviétique dans
le bloc oriental sous influence
soviétique
certains pays signent le pacte de
varsovie pour se protéger des américains
toutefois l'armée soviétique réprime
durement des mouvements indépendantistes
en hongrie sans que les nations
occidentales puisse intervenir
c'est la guerre froide entre les deux
blocs qui ne peuvent plus entrer en
guerre directement à cause de la
dissuasion nucléaire acquises par les
états unis l'union soviétique la
république populaire de chine le
royaume-uni et la france
l'europe cependant on a assez des
conflits ces nations sont jetés un
modèle d'intégration qui les mettrait à
jamais à l'abri d'une nouvelle guerre le
ministre français sumann a alors l'idée
de mettre les industries européennes
liées aux armements sous le contrôle
réciproque des deux principaux
producteurs de fer et de charbon
la france et l'allemagne il s'ensuit le
traité de rome où la communauté
économique européenne est créé son but
est un rapprochement économique qui
permet la libre circulation des
personnes des marchandises des services
et des capitaux entre les pays membres
les signataires sont la france l'italie
l'allemagne de l'ouest
la belgique le luxembourg et les pays
bas
chypre prend enfin son indépendance
vis-à-vis du royaume-uni et passe au
statut de république
malte aussi proclame l'indépendance et
la république mr s dans le commonwealth
une organisation composée du royaume uni
et de ses colonies dans le bloc oriental
l'armée soviétique intervient encore
étouffant les rébellion indépendantiste
en tchéquie dans le bloc occidental
la communauté économique européenne
s'élargit avec l'adhésion du danemark de
l'irlande et du royaume uni
a chip les chypriotes grecs et les
chypriotes d'ethnie turc s'affrontent
durement la turquie occupe alors
militairement le nord de l'île le nomme
en république turque de chypre mais
cette république n'est pas reconnue par
la communauté internationale à
l'exception de la turquie
au portugal une révolution met fin à la
dictature militaire et la république est
rétabli malte sort enfin du commonwealth
et proclame sa totale indépendance
en grèce après la dictature des colonels
la république est proclamée dans
l'espagne où blé par des luttes
d'indépendance menée par les basques le
général franco rétabli la monarchie sous
régime constitutionnel
actuellement tous les royaumes et les
principautés d'europe ont embrassé la
monarchie constitutionnelle avec un
premier ministre comme chef du
gouvernement
la communauté économique européenne
s'élargir encore avec l'adhésion de la
grèce de l'espagne et du portugal
un grand changement s'opère en union
soviétique et la pérestroïka de michel
gorbatchev met fin au bloc communiste et
la république fédérale de russie est
proclamé
cela permet à l'allemagne d'abattre le
mur de berlin et de se réunifier en un
seul pays à la tchécoslovaque il
redevenir deux pays distinctes la
république tchèque et la république de
slovaquie et à la pologne la bulgarie
l'estonie
la lettonie la lituanie la hongrie
la roumanie la moldavie l'ukraine et la
biélorussie de devenir des républiques
indépendantes l'indépendance s'est
déclaré aussi en slovénie en croatie en
macédoine et en bosnie-herzégovine par
rapport à la république fédérale de
yougoslavie qui est désormais réduit à
la seule union serbie monténégro
le régime communiste est abandonnée même
en albanie qui passe au statut de
république démocratique
avec l'adhésion de l'autriche de la
finlande et de la suède
la communauté économique européenne
devient l'union européenne et met en
circulation sa devise l'euro une monnaie
commune aux états membres de la zone
euro
cela attire l'estonie la lettonie la
lituanie
la pologne la tchéquie la slovaquie
la hongrie la slovénie malte et chypre
qui rejoigne l'union européenne
dans les balkans la serbie et le
monténégro se séparent le venant de
république indépendance
l'union européenne devient l'europe des
après l'adhésion de la roumanie et de la
bulgarie en serbie
la province du kosovo proclame la
république mais elle n'est pas reconnu
par la majorité des pays membres de
l'organisation des nations unies à ce
jour la croatie a d'ores et déjà rejoint
l'union européenne le monténégro
l'albanie la macédoine l'islande et la
turquie demande l'adhésion à l'union
européenne dont la zone euro s'est
élargi à 16 nations mais la requête de
la turquie est conditionné par les
troubles entre les deux communautés de
chypre
la grande histoire de l'europe vous a
été compté
sur ce continent magnifique s'est peu à
peu bâti la civilisation occidentale qui
inspire maintenant par ses valeurs
le monde entier sur cette terre
millénaire les nations parmi les plus
puissantes du monde se sont constitués
bouleversant souvent le destin des
peuples
aujourd'hui après trois mille ans de
conflit l'europe
animé par l'idée audacieuse une
structure supranationale inédite dans
l'histoire de l'humanité est parvenu à
unir pacifiquement dans l'union
européenne des pays de langue et de
culture différence
cela lui a valu le prix nobel de la paix
en 2012 la suprématie économique que
mondiale et surtout une période de paix
la plus longue depuis les temps anciens
de l' empire romain
il est bien loin l'instant où la
princesse europe se baignant près d'une
plage croiser à son regard avec celui 2
le roi des dieux